some nevadans are really fed up with the
state's covid 19 vaccine rollout saying
they've been waiting just
too long to get their shot this is more
and more vaccination clinics are popping
up around the valley
orco mana joining us live to explain
some of the frustrations we're hearing
about
orco
well brian vaccinations for this week
are now available
at chuck minker sports complex other
sites include the pearson community
center
desert pines high school the catchment
center and of course the southern nevada
health district but appointments
are still only for those 70 and older
leaving other seniors
irritated for people like me
we live in fear every day shirley bryce
says 66 years old has two
underlying heart conditions but still
can't get the covet 19 vaccine
according to nevada's vaccination
playbook only though 70 and older as
well as front line community support
workers are eligible right now
i am so frustrated that's why bryce
started this online petition to include
65 to 69 year olds now
it's also because of certain people
jumping the line the i-team recently
reporting elected officials in henderson
got vaccinated the same day as first
responders
we are dying from covet and it's so
maddening to see younger people
non-essential workers getting the
vaccine
efforts are being made to speed up
distribution the city of las vegas
announcing those 70 and older as well as
utility workers can get the vaccine this
week at chuck banker's sports complex
we've continued to improve dr christina
madison administers the coven 19 vaccine
and says what will help
is johnson and johnson's vaccine if that
gets
authorization then that's another
vaccine that we will have
to be able to get through the priority
groups quicker while bryce understands
this is a complex process
she remains firm we want the state to
change the
playbook right now
now i reached out to the governor's
office to see if seniors age 65 to 69
will be made eligible for the vaccine
soon but i did not hear a response
tonight
in the meantime bryce's page here
the petition has over 120 signatures
reporting live tonight orco mana 8 news
now